[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the first part
of the making of planet coaster and just
to clarify by that I don't mean the game
itself but a roller coaster which I made
in the game and released a couple of
days ago thankfully I saved some time
lapses of its because I got so many
requests to turn this into a how it's
made type of series that I figured I
could take these time lapses and
actually make this two-part video series
out of it and in this series I'll just
show you how I made the coaster itself
how I make the planet that it revolves
around and how I construct the entire
idea that somehow it's out there up in
space when in reality it's all just in
game or most of it is at least so
without further ado let's get into the
time-lapse so of course the thing that I
had to start with is making the planet
itself and I did this in a way which is
very straight forward but in hindsight I
think there could have been easier ways
if you want to do this yourself one
thing which you could do is actually
make a perfect sphere out of scenery and
then terraform around that in this case
though I just decided to take the
terraforming tool only and just work on
a sphere just carefully changing some
things here and there until it looks
like a perfect universe fear it's
definitely not perfect in the end but
with a lot of smoothing and try on error
to get all of the bumps out there it's
more or less enough of a ball to turn it
into an actual planet the characteristic
then I feel matters most about the
planet is the size of it I wanted to
make sure that it was large enough to
actually seem like an actual microscopic
planets and large enough to fit some
buildings and trees on without set
buildings and trees completely touring
the planet itself while at the same time
making it small enough to realistically
well not really realistically but to
allow me to actually build a coaster
around it if it were much larger it'd be
hard to have the coast to revolve around
the planet without losing too much speed
and also it would take much more time to
do this entire project and in the end I
think
in game it took around 20 hours spread
over two days as it was just a small
Christmas vacation kind of project and
I'm actually really happy with how
little time it took this build and most
of my time was actually spent in sort of
creating the illusion that it's much
more than it really is whenever unity
it's just a floating bubble of
terraforming with a bunch of trees
around it so going almost into the
coastal layout here I was pretty
confident that I could make the course
the layouts in the way that I wanted
since the sphere is quite small because
the way that I wanted to make the
coastal layouts is in that kind of
confusing way where it's not quite clear
what's up and what's down because
obviously this planet being in space you
kind of do want to get rid of the idea
that there is up and down at all and
this was very challenging I didn't
really have any kind of planning before
I went into making this layout because I
had no clue how to prepare for making a
coastal layouts around super small
planets it's not exactly something that
I've done before but the one thing that
I did want to make sure I did with this
layout is to make the riders lose their
orientation and that's why I decided
that it would be best to make this
layout out of large sweeping curves that
don't change their direction too much
and mostly stay very close to the ground
of the planet itself and you can see
this in the first curve already there
the only reason why it goes completely
to the bottom of the planet is because I
wanted to start off the ride with the
zero-g roll already like lose all of
your orientation what exactly is where
since the zero during that entire zero-g
roll it starts going inverted already
which is already kind of confusing since
the zero zero of course banks 360
degrees but also those 360 degrees
you're upside down which is already kind
of weird and that is more or less the
pollock short for this entire station
thing that you're coming out of and you
also already make quite a bit of speed
during that but after that first curve
coming up again I wanted to make the
small upwards launching L AM launched
parts just to make sure that you don't
lose
your momentum I wanted to make the
entire ride quite fast and it's a pretty
easy way to make it yeah just to make
the coaster not lose any speed and to
make sure that it can stay close to the
planet itself at all times and also one
thing that I wanted to make sure with
this is that it has enough speed at the
end to make its way back to the station
without having to add another little to
the top of the planets because that
would obviously disrupt any idea that
there is no up and down on this planet
so that was quite important and then
after that li m launch I figured I would
have a section of the coaster with two
very large sweeping curves and we're
working on the second one over here and
basically what I wanted to do with this
is half these curves that are mostly
horizontal because one thing that
obviously gives away what's the bottom
and what's the top of this planet is the
fact that the cars will always gravitate
toward the bottom of the planet so I
wanted to have some curves that seem
like they're horizontal curves but are
actually kind of diagonal curves and the
cars don't really accelerate too much
over the course of these curves to make
it very obvious where up and down is at
least that's what I was going for and I
hope I kind of succeeded in that and
instead the cars just have a very even
fast speed going very close to the
planets and then the final two elements
are these large helixes which are almost
exactly vertical which kind of make it
seem as is as if the vertical side of
this planet is actually horizontal these
are technically just loops but they're
banked outward to make it seem as if
they are helixes and one of the things
which kind of helps with this idea is
these little airtime Hills that aren't
actually airtime Hills they're actually
Hills then extend outward and would give
some lethal G's in real life but in this
case it kind of makes it look as if the
ending of the ride is a bunch of helixes
with airtime Hills and that basically
concludes the ride which has three basic
parts I'd say with the first part being
the zero-g gyros and the launch section
the second one being those large
sweeping
curves where it's hard to tell on what
side of the planet you are really at and
lost point being those two helixes and
after that I wanted to move into making
the station of the coaster and this was
all just a lot of stuff that I was
winging at the time I didn't really
think it was too important to get into
the designs of the the station and the
other console at this point the only
thing that I had prepared for myself was
that I wanted to have two consoles on
this planet the reason why I wanted to
have two is because one console would
very easily give away what's the top and
what's the bottom of the console and
exactly removed that suspense of
disbelief that this is an actual planet
so I wanted to have two castles and this
also gives the planet a very nice kind
of duality structure to it it actually
seems a lot like yin yang if I look back
at it with one side you know this being
the daytime side and the other side
being the nighttime side and they're
both kind of separated by these large
sweeping curves of the coaster itself
which is very interesting but there's
definitely a duality in the planet in
that sense not just because it looks
good but also because it removes the
idea that you know there is up and down
it just makes it seem more like you can
go anywhere on this thing and because
there's such a duality between the two
halves of the planet I also wanted to
make sure that these two castles
are similar in a way but also very
distinct so the top castle here I wanted
to mostly use the domes in the game and
make it more of a wide building than it
really is tall so it's mostly just
characterized by this very large dome
which sits just on top of the station
and then there's of course the domed
kind of onion tower right next to it
which and we're looking a lot like a
mosque at this point which is something
that I did kind of want to avoid I just
wanted to make it look a bit more
neutral kind of fantasy esque so I hope
with adding a lot of these different
gothic elements to it around all the
detailing
especially the windows and the doors and
the arches that it's it's a bit less
pinpoint of all
any kind of location or inspiration it's
really just a castle for the sake of
there being a castle on top of the
planet and I also put these battlements
on the side or um they're not called
battlements the battlements set of
things on top of the walls I put these
buttresses on the side of the building
which are a bit of a gothic touch as
well they're really just for fun because
they don't actually support anything and
they're structurally completely
illogical but it's it's a nice touch of
detail and I wanted to add into the East
station I mean it's not like this
builder is very logical to begin with
and they decide I'm actually using a
surprising amount of just simple in-game
elements and not really making anything
myself since I didn't want to spend too
much time on this castle it's not really
focus to make the castle Lukas detailed
or intricate or unique itself it's
really just a build that I wanted to
have on top of this planet to shape the
look of the planet as a whole
so it's it's quite simple and I put a
bunch of rocks and foliage around its to
detail it and blend it in a little bit
with the rest of the planets as well
what was a little bit tricky about the
castle is that it doesn't actually move
with the curvature of the planets it's
completely vertical for the entire thing
but around the castle the trees as you
can see are already starting to curve
toward the curvature of the planets
since I wanted to follow the direction
that the planet is going with all of the
trees to make it look even more as if
there's no actual up and down and
everything is really just sprouting from
the planet itself but it does look a
little bit weird I feel very close to
the to the castle here since you can
already see the trees curving out in
this ridiculous sense which doesn't
really make any sense now that I haven't
even talked about that yet by the way I
just wanna very quickly say that there
was a lot of mario galaxy inspiration
definitely in this and as you can
probably tell with the castle right now
especially there is definitely some
inspiration from the first galaxies in
mario galaxy where you also have this
kind of console that you're starting out
with
and of course you have all of these very
small planetoids with weird gravity and
everything just coming out of these very
small planets that some somehow have the
same gravity the gravitational pull that
the earth has which makes no sense but
it's an amazing concept and that's
definitely where I took a lot of
inspiration from other than of course is
the name of the game because obviously I
actually that's not quite as obvious I
came up with the title for this coaster
before I made the coaster itself I just
wanted to make a coaster called planet
coaster and themed after planets for
such a long time because it's the name
of the game and I just thought it would
be funny to do it so here you go that's
basically the reason why I make this
thing in the first place now another
thing that was very tough actually my
main challenge with this coaster was the
supports if I were to let the game make
all of the supports for this coaster
they would just go straight to the earth
and that would be a huge problem but
what also proved to be a problem is that
you're not allowed to intersect the
scenery with the coaster track so none
of the supports actually touch the
coaster I try to get as close as I could
with making all of these custom supports
and get them to almost intersect the
coaster track but at no point do the
supports even touch the track there is
always a super super small distance
between the supports and the track so
it's not actually technically supported
I just needed to get all of these
supports and to create the illusion of
everything being pulled toward the
planets which I have here these supports
are also the reason why the track isn't
really longer than it is since custom
supporting on its own is already quite
challenging with you know not being able
to put the supports into the coaster
track but with these supports I also had
to make sure that every support goes
directly into the center of the planets
so it took a lot of trial and error to
get all of these supports to go into the
right direction and actually supports
the coaster in a way that would make
sense if this
it actually had a gravitational pull so
um yeah in the end that meant making a
lot of these different supports and I
cut out a lot of the support making from
the time-lapse videos I think it's just
a bit of a boring thing it's something I
had to do but nothing that really
defines the coaster the only case in
which I would say I think these supports
are very defining in this sort of
scenery kind of purpose it is for the
tallest points the first 0 0 has some
supports that always take out from the
planets and you can see very clearly and
the same goes for this original the
zero-g roll that launches over the
station which has some tall supports
which kind of fit a scenery kind of
purpose they just make it seem even more
like it's a small planet and it's a
small planet with actual gravity but
that aside these supports were more of a
nuisance than an actual fun bit of
making this coaster so I was just really
happy to be done with these supports in
the end speaking of the end by the way
that's also the end of this episode
thank you guys for watching so far and
stay tuned for the next video in which I
will show you how I finish the planet
itself and make the space around the
planet and the video editing as well
[Music]